as part of doing bits and bytes some
fairly low level stuff we have mentioned
the possibility of a thing called binary
coded decimal and that effectively IBM
in their mainframe days led the charge
on this now done a video on this and how
it led eventually to extended binary
coded decimal I would like to talk about
what is BCD why is it necessary and in
particular that's to answer a question
that I did really think about in my
early days of doing heavyweight macho
calculations overnight it's effectively
how does this stuff ever get printed out
I thought well what's the biggest ratio
between actual computation and fairly
quick printout as I can think of not my
quantum calculations they're
minor-league those of you are familiar
with Douglas Adams and Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy which was made into
a BBC series here and also became a
movie I think we'll know that Douglas
who was a very far seeing guy had this
idea of the ultimate computer called
deep thought it was years ahead of his
time because I'm pretty sure that deep
blue IBM's chess machine deepmind the AI
machine that's doing go is it and so on
and you know deep learning deep
everything not at all sure it isn't all
down to Douglas Adams I just have to
point out here that the ultimate
computer was the earth Oh in the family
there will be some fancy Murnau so oh I
see I just nevertheless deep thought was
I was asked deep thought what is the
answer to life the universe and
everything and several million years
later presumably even with quantum
assistance
[Music]
the answer to life the universe and
everything is 42 42 my first thought
when I was laughing out loud at ours I
thought what's 42 in binary is there
something special about it and yeah how
would you convert the binary string 442
into being literally four and two on a
piece of line printer out port 42 in
binary is one zero one zero one zero
how do we know that that's 42 or
starting at the right its powers of two
so two to the zero is units then twos
then 4 then 8 then 16 and 32
armed with that knowledge we say okay
it's a 2 plus an 8 which is 10 plus a 32
is 42 pretty good look a six bit
representation for a two-digit decimal
number but if you feed that into a
printer you're not going to get 42
printed out because by and large they do
not interpret binary so where does the
printable form of 42 come from and the
answer is it goes way back to the fact
that IBM and their computing machines
way back at the start of the 20th
century they were the horath company you
know doing census details controlling
elections from punch cards and some IBM
early electronic computers I think the
IBM 650 was it actually did work
internally on decimal just like Tommy
flowers I think they both used by Quinn
but the pressure was on from binary
based hardware to say it's this is more
efficient by far you may mad not to use
it okay so is IBM but although it's got
to be a binary representation we want to
directly link it to the decimal that
will ultimately be printed out
now think about it that's easy to do but
what would this binary coded decimal be
for 42 every decimal position can range
from nought to 9 so how many bits do we
need to represent 9 well we know that 3
bits isn't enough 3 bits goes up to 1 1
1 which is 7 but you need a snide so
you've got to go to that 4th bit and you
end up of course with 8 being 1 & 3
zeros and 9 be 1 0 0 1 ah I hear several
of you say but you don't stop there you
can go on to hexadecimal and this is
precisely the thing with BCD you must
not let it go over into the hexadecimal
range from 10 to 16 because the average
person once answers out in decimals in
hexadecimal so here we go then look 0 1
0 0 taken as a grouping of bits on its
own that's nothing in the unit's column
0 in the 2's column one in the fourth
column 0 in the eights column that
represents decimal 4 right next door to
it is a separate 4-bit entity if I write
down 0 0 1 0 well that represents 2 in
its simplest form that is what binary
coded decimal is and you just use them
in full bit nibbles now we all know a
nibble is half a bite a bite equals 8
bits while it does in the modern world
so half a bite
well the name nibble caught on for
obvious reasons a nibble being a small
bite and I'll use an eye but some people
like to extend the joke as much as
possible and actually spell nibble with
a why I don't mind and then the ball can
hold a hex digit you might say oh well
that's it then if I fed 0 1 0 0 down a
serial line into a printer it would
coffin to life and print for no not
quite
but we're getting close because what
we're going to ask ourselves is
this whole printout thing is treating
decimal digits as characters they're not
being thought of in their numeric sense
at all it's just any other character is
like an A or B is Ed an exclamation mark
or whatever the ASCII committee in the
nineteen sixties didn't just work in a
vacuum they knew was IBM who they loved
and hated have been doing for years and
it basically said it is so much easier
if you base what's printed ultimately on
a BCD representation but put a special
marker at the front of the BCD to pad it
out wait an a bit bite but do it in such
a way that in a sense the codes that are
gonna do 0 to 9 are in a sensible place
now what does that mean well let's do
ask you first even though historically
it was second in ASCII the digits occupy
from three zero hexadecimal to three
nine hexadecimal what it means is if you
have got shall we say this 401 zero zero
that is your hex nibble before all you
have to do to make it printable as an
ASCII four is to glue on the left hand
then hexadecimal three which is the same
as decimal three is 0 0 1 1 so 0 0 1 1
prepended to 0 1 0 0 gives you an 8-bit
entity which if you fire that down as a
line printer
it'll coffin into action and print a 4
notice that when I say glue on at the
front in order for it to be efficient
you don't want to be adding on something
that was will cause carries if you see
what I mean you need to park it on a
multiple of 16 and then what will happen
is that whatever way you convert your 4
into being 34 hex it will not cause rip
Carrie's which are inefficient okay say
IBM mainframe types why not historically
tell the youth of today what IBM did
originally
same idea ask you learnt a lot from what
IBM did in IBM M stick you don't prepend
a three hexadecimal you prepend an F 1 1
1 1 but the principle is the same
yeah it's cleanly on that boundary so
that's not so crucial fact in making BCD
to print it out results be fast and
efficient you need to be able to put
something in there that's low cost
because you're going to be doing
millions of these BCD to ASCII app stick
conversions so that is a very sort of
crucial fact to get hold of to try and
reduce the conversion burden before
print out so in many ways then that's
much of the story
if you once got it into BCD then both
ASCII or if you're still on IBM
mainframes app stick do make it easy for
you to get into a printable form very
quickly and of course the i/o routines
hidden underneath Fortran and C will be
well aware of this converting from pure
binary 101 o 1 o 2 42 BC D 0 1 0 0 0 0 1
0 they look very different when you get
onto telling us how to do it it's not
going to be a cheap operation is it
because that's the hard bit it's all
very well saying getting from BCD to ask
is piece of cake but what about getting
from binary to BCD and the answer is
there's bound to be over hers there and
it's bound to be something that you
probably want to eliminate
and so that's affect some people in the
commercial computing Center say look
binary to BCD will turn out to be
expensive tell you what if what we do is
totally trivial and really isn't rocket
science wouldn't we be better off to try
and devise software or
even hardware assistance circuits to do
all the arithmetic on a b c d notation
never converted into pure binary because
if all you're doing is adding up how
many voters in you know Norwalk County
or something I voted for such-and-such
you don't need all these huge great
binary things that numerical analysts
use you just counting numbers and even
if you're looking at somebody's balance
in dollars and cents surely that's
simple enough arithmetic is better to
perhaps pay a little penalty for doing
BCD arithmetic because you can overcome
that penalty a bit by having specialized
hardware why not do it all in BCD and
then you don't have the binary to BCD
overhead all you have to do after you've
done your BCD arithmetic is Slipper four
FS on the front end if it's hep stick a
threes a three hexadecimal of its ASCII
and that's it prints out there is one
classic one well you really can pick up
that it's very advantageous to do it in
BCD if you think about the number zero
point one zero which might represent ten
cents shall we say you know your your
bank accounts being drained down it's
down to its the last ten cents so here
you've got zero point one zero that's
point one in decimal what is it in
binary oh dear
you look at what it is in binary zero
point three zeros 1 1 0 0 1 1 0 0 1 1 0
0 and it goes on forever there is no
exact representation of point 1 decimal
as a binary expansion it just doesn't
stop and accountants and actuaries get
paranoid about that oh I know it'll
never happen but I hate the idea that
rounding might go wrong and my client
should my clients balance might drop to
9 cents instead of 10 cents how about
some other examples of things that use
BCD just to finish off with I don't know
if I've got it here
to dig it out of there Shawn eventually
is a little hand calculator what better
place to use BCD it's utterly display
dominated apart from things like square
root that's probably about the most
complex thing that you can ask a simple
four function calculator to do but
mostly its additions subtractions
different simple divides and oh man they
use BCD another example of simple
devices you see in a shopping mall or
whatever that could use BCD digital
clocks
it makes eminent sense to use BCD
because it's the display and the change
in the display is a happening all the
time every second but the actual
incrementing is trivial you don't need
to convert into binary to add one second
to a digital display
you really don't live with the BCD focus
on the display because that's what
matters above all else the luckless and
dong was faced with these guys holding
this black box and I said are we here
via back channels from your users they
are not happy with the performance of
your machine on the they call it is
their database